l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines se développe sorti de terre
près du centre commercial sqy ouest un
nouveau bâtiment accueille désormais les
étudiants de l'ufr des sciences de la
santé communément appelée fac de
médecine les jeunes ont découvert leurs
locaux flambant neufs leur donne tout ce
que vous savez grâce à un nouveau
bâtiment ouais il a été conçu stan est
déjà rentrée n'ont jamais fait la
première qu'est ce que vous en attendez
de ce bâti bail doit il doit être bien
doit être moderne et moderne c'est
toujours mieux il ya moins de problèmes
techniques c'est peut-être mieux pour
apprendre aussi
moi je n'aime pas trop
mais on n'a plus de repères c'est pas
nous
non non ce qu'on n'aime pas
ce matin 856 étudiants de première année
ont réalisé leur rentrée accueilli par
bill doyle ce qui change c'est d'abord
et avant tout d'avoir un bâtiment
moderne
construit selon les normes hqe club et
surtout avec un équipement informatique
et numérique tout à fait adaptée aux
défis modernes de l'enseignement avec
des tableaux interactifs
de quoi rassurer les premières années
qui devront se partager long de 200
places en filières médicales et
paramédicales